[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm Laura, from Google.
Did you know that you can use
the Google Cloud Platform to
build your own mobile backend on
Google's infrastructure in
five minutes?
Let me show you how.
In this tutorial, we'll be
building an app that allows a
user to shop smart by getting
information on products she's
looking for at the store
she's in, as well
as find stores nearby.
We'll be using some custom code
to wire a basic Android
app front end with an App Engine
Cloud backend using
Google Cloud Endpoints, so the
phone can determine customer
location, and the app can locate
nearby stores and allow
the customer to get relevant
offers and recommendations.
Let's get started.
I've already installed and
configured my IDE with all the
right tools and SDKs.
First, we're going to create
the project for the Android
client application, and start
building the app.
We'll create an entity class to
define the data structure,
generate Cloud Endpoint classes
to give us the backend
infrastructure and APIs, and
then generate a related client
library to make calling
the server APIs from
our mobile app easy.
In our Eclipse project, let's
create a new class and
name it check in.
These classes allow for
communication between the
client and the backend.
Click to generate the Cloud
Endpoint class.
You can see now that the check
in endpoint.java file is
generated in our Apps backend.
To generate the related client
library, let's open the
package explorer and
our project.
In a few clicks, we generate
the check in
endpoint client library.
Now that we've created the
communication mechanism, we
need to add more logic to the
mobile client app to talk to
the entity and Cloud
Endpoint classes.
Once we do this, the
app will be able to
call back to the server.
For our app, this means we'll
be able to retrieve store
information contained in
the backend data store.
Let's create a new entity
class in our app.
This will represent places--
such as stores--
near the customer's current
location in real time.
Let's create that new class
and name it Place.
We'll navigate to the package
explorer and generate a Cloud
Endpoint class.
Then, we'll also generate
another Cloud
Endpoint client library.
Now that we've told the app
how to understand store
addresses, let's modify the
client to actually obtain
information from the backend
and display it in our app.
What I'm doing is expanding the
MainActivity.java section,
where our front end code is
located, and adding in more
code, which includes the global
results list variable.
This contains the information
about the store locations
obtained from the backend.
And now we've got the app
infrastructure in place
between the client and the
mobile backend using Google
Cloud Endpoints.
We just did a lot.
We created a bunch of objects
and classes, built the
infrastructure, wired up the
Android app to call back to
the server, and got the app to
display a list of stores.
Next, let's add logic that
allows the customer to perform
the actual tasks of checking
in to a place and obtaining
information about the
sales and offers.
First, we need to create the
client-user interface so users
can access the information,
then we can add offers and
recommendations logic to the
backend and to the client.
Let's modify a few files to
improve the interface.
We replace TextView with
ListView, which contains the
code to list nearby places.
We add the
placesListClickListener event
handler, which helps the client
understand user clicks,
and lets it know when to
activate the logic that
performs the check in tasks.
Finally, in the onPostExecute
method, we create a list
adapter to better display the
information with icons.
Let's now add a few things to
the MainActivity.java file to
improve the interface
even more.
We add activity_main.xml, which
defines the UI layout
for buttons and places.
We add place_item.xml, which
contains information about
display format and position.
And finally, we add strings.xml,
which contains
pre-defined strings to display
when the user might get
relevant offers or
recommendations.
Now that we've created the
client-user interface, we need
to add classes that allow the
app to obtain information
about offers available and
shopping recommendations for
each store.
We can add the Offer.java
entity class and the
Recommendation.java
entity class--
one for gathering offers, and
one for gathering shopping
recommendations.
In the same way we added the
CheckIn.java class, we're
going to create our related
OfferEndpoint.java class and
RecommendationsEndpoint.java
class.
Again, this creates the related
client libraries
automatically.
Finally, we're going to add
the logic to the client so
that the customer can actually
see offers and shopping
recommendations displayed.
We modify MainActivity.java
to add the
placesListClickListener event
handler, so that when a
customer clicks on an item in
the list of nearby places,
it'll provide offers and
recommendations.
We're done with all
the coding.
Let's deploy an instance
to see our app live.
Check it out.
In five minutes, we were able to
control our Android app by
writing custom code to wire
the app to Google Cloud
Endpoints, enhancing the
user experience,
and saving us time.
Now, you should go download the
code and the tutorial, and
give it a shot doing
it on your own.
[MUSIC PLAYING]